in the 19th century the Menai Strait in
Wales forms a formidable obstacle for
people traveling to Ireland the engineer
given the job of spanning this
treacherous waterway is Thomas Telford a
62 year old self-taught Scot by the time
he arrived at Menai Telford had a
reputation as one of the finest civil
engineers in britain be given this huge
job to improve the main coaching route
between Britain and Ireland
Telford considers constructing an arch
bridge from cast iron but he would have
to use scaffolding to support the arch
while it's being built this would block
the movement of ships along the busy
waterway the planners don't accept this
so Telford goes back to the first
principles of bridge design
[Music]
rope bridges have been used to cross
rivers since ancient times and
Mountaineers like Mark handford still
use them today so the crews both crucial
thing in it in a former bridge is the
anchor coins so we've got the tree as a
solid anchor without these anchors the
whole bridge is going to collapse three
so three so for it next they pull the
ropes taut
c33 stop that's it there the bottom rope
carries the load the top ropes are for
holding on to once you get a straight
spring in stringers on it the grade
these are really good now owe yourself
support now tying them together forms a
rudimentary suspension bridge it's fine
for soldiers but would hardly do for the
London to Dublin stagecoach adding
planks of wood to form a deck makes the
bridge easier to cross and iron chains
allow it to carry heavier loads but the
deck still sags to build a truly modern
suspension bridge the engineers must
find a way to flatten the sagging day
the answer is to suspend it from stone
towers then extend the ropes downwards
to level the deck
Telford now has a design that can bridge
the many straights but he still has the
problem of securing the chains at each
end do you think of pulling down that
chain it's going to give unless it's
really firmly anchored and that was tell
first challenge
somehow Telford must anchor the chains
not to the trees but deep into the rocky
banks on either side of the Straits to
do so
workers blast their way through the rock
to create an 18 metre long tunnel at the
end of the tunnel they positioned strong
iron frames the end of the chains thread
into the tunnel and are secured to the
frame with three meter long bolts metal
braces wedge the bolts and frame firmly
into the cavern the only way this
Anchorage can fail is if the rock gives
way
Telford triumphs the Newbridge helps
reduce the journey time from London to
Dublin by nine hours
his Anchorage's have held the hundred
and seventy-seven meter deck in place
for over a hundred and eighty years
[Music]
today it still carries thousands of
vehicles every week
as the first great modern suspension
bridge it shines a light on the future